ARE YOU AWARE OF THE CHARGES
THAT MICHAEL JACKSON
IS CURRENTLY FACING?
YES, SIR.
AH, AND FOR THE RECORD,
THESE CHARGES HURT ME THE MOST.
SO HE'S GUILTY.
LOOK, MAN.
LOOK.
MICHAEL JACKSON HAS MANY FACES.
NONE OF THEM
LOOK GUILTY TO ME.
YOU GOT TO LOOK IN THE EYES,
NOT THE NOSES.
HE'S BEEN ACCUSED OF THIS
MORE THAN ONCE.
SO?
SOME PEOPLE SAY THAT CUCUMBERS
TASTE BETTER PICKLED.
WHAT?
HUH?
WHAT IF I TOLD YOU
THAT THE ACCUSERS
CORRECTLY DESCRIBED MICHAEL'S
PENIS TO INVESTIGATORS.
SIR, I HAVE NEVER SEEN
MICHAEL'S ALLEGED PENIS,
BUT I BET YOU THAT I COULD
DESCRIBE IT, ALL RIGHT?
LET ME GUESS.
THERE'S A HEAD,
A SHAFT, SOME BALLS,
HAIR--MAYBE PRESSED, PERMED HAIR
WITH GLITTER SPRINKLED ON IT.
THAT IS CORRECT.
WHOA, HOW'D I KNOW?
COME ON, DUDE,
I COULDN'T PICK MY OWN PENIS
OUT OF A LINEUP, ALL RIGHT?
AND ME AND MY PENIS
IS LIKE THIS, SON.
WHAT ABOUT MICHAEL
SAYING IT'S OKAY
TO HAVE CHILDREN
SLEEP WITH HIM?
THAT DON'T MEAN ANYTHING.
I'M SURE THERE'S PLENTY OF KIDS
THAT SLEEP IN THE BED
WITH THEIR ADULTS ALL THE TIME
AND NOTHING HAPPENS.
SO YOU DO YOU THINK
MICHAEL JACKSON
IS GUILTY OF THE CHARGES
AGAINST HIM?
NO, MAN.
HE MADE THRILLER.
THRILLER.
SO YOU'D LET YOUR CHILDREN
SLEEP WITH HIM.
(BLEEP) NO!
EW.
ARE YOU AWARE
THAT ROBERT BLAKE
IS FACING
A CHARGE OF MURDER?
OH, YEAH.
BARETTA DID THAT (BLEEP).
MR. CHAPPELLE,
ARE YOU AWARE THAT ROBERT KELLY
IS BEING CHARGED
WITH CHILD PORNOGRAPHY?
YES, I'VE HEARD
OF SUCH THINGS.
YOU'VE SEEN
THE VIDEO TAPES?
HAVE I SEEN IT?
LIKE 80 TIMES.
YOU KNOW THE PART WHERE HE'S
WAITING FOR HER TO COME OVER,
AND HE'S LOOKING IN
THE CAMERA LIKE...
[grunting]
SO YOU THINK THAT IT WAS
ROBERT KELLY ON THE TAPE?
WELL, I'D HAVE
TO SAY IT WAS.
SO THEN YOU BELIEVE
HE URINATED
ON A 15-YEAR-OLD GIRL.
WHOA, HOLD ON, LADY!
I DIDN'T SAY ALL THAT.
YOU KNOW WITH THESE TAPES
THEY CAN DO A LOT OF THINGS.
FOR ALL I KNOW,
THAT PISS WAS DIGITAL.
THEY GET CRAZY
WITH SPECIAL EFFECTS.
LOOK, LOOK, CHECK THIS OUT.
I DIDN'T EVEN JUST DO THAT.
DID I DO THAT?
THAT PISS WAS DIGITAL.
THEY'LL DO CRAZY STUFF
WITH SPECIAL EFFECTS.
WHAT ABOUT THE GIRL
CORROBORATING THE STORY?
SO WHAT?
HOW MUCH MONEY DOES
THIS GIRL STAND TO MAKE
BY "CO-OBORATING"
THIS STORY?
I TELL YOU WHAT,
YOU GIVE ME THAT KIND OF MONEY,
R. KELLY CAN FART
IN MY DINNER TONIGHT.
SPRAY-FART.
SO BESIDES THE TAPE
AND THE GIRL
CORROBORATING
THE ALLEGATIONS,
WHAT MORE WOULD IT TAKE
FOR YOU TO BELIEVE HE'S GUILTY?
ALL RIGHT, IF I SAW A TAPE
OF R. KELLY PEEING ON A GIRL
WHILE HE WAS SINGING
"PISS ON YOU"...
♪ LOVERS WANNA LOVE... ♪
AND THE GIRL WAS HOLDING
TWO FORMS OF GOVERNMENT I.D.,
WHILE A POLICE OFFICER
WAS THERE,
LIKE, FOUR OR FIVE
OF MY BUDDIES,
AND NEAL TAKING NOTES...
WELL--
I'M NOT FINISHED.
AND HIS GRANDMOTHER
HAS TO BE THERE
TO CONFIRM HIS IDENTIFY.
THAT'S MY ROBERT,
ALWAYS PEEING ON PEOPLE.
DON'T FORGET HER HAIR, ROBERT.
YES, GRANDMOTHER.
MR. CHAPPELLE,
ISN'T THAT EXCESSIVE?
NO, NO, IT'S NOT EXCESSIVE.
LISTEN, LADY, THE BURDEN
OF PROOF IS ON THE STATE.
ON THE STATE!
YOU HAVE GOT
TO PROVE TO ME
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT
WHETHER OR NOT
THIS MAN IS A PISSER.
AREN'T YOUR DOUBTS
UNREASONABLE?
NO, IT'S NOT UNREASONABLE.
LOOK, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
A JUSTICE SYSTEM
THAT HAD 500 PEOPLE
WHOSE CASES WERE OVERTURNED
BY DNA EVIDENCE.
I'VE SEEN A TAPE WHERE
FIVE COPS BEAT UP A NIGGA,
AND THEY SAID
THAT THEY HAD REASONABLE DOUBT.
I GOT MY DOUBTS TOO, ALL RIGHT?
HOW COME THEY DIDN'T FIND
BIG AND TUPAC'S MURDERERS
BUT THEY ARREST
O.J. THE NEXT DAY?
NICOLE SIMPSON CAN'T RAP.
I WANT JUSTICE!
YOU ARE ALL--
THIS WHOLE GODDAMN COURT
IS OUT OF ORDER.
EVERYBODY!
MR. CHAPPELLE,
YOU'RE DISMISSED.
AND THAT'S FROM THE HEART.